>>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOW
DEBATING WHETHER TO DECLARE A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY FOR
MONKEYPOX.
BUT OFFICIALS SAY DATA
SHORTFALLS ARE HINDERING
MITIGATION EFFORTS RIGHT NOW.
THE U.S. HAS JUST RECORDED 3,000
CASES OF MONKEYPOX.
THE CDC DIRECTOR SAYS HER AGENCY
HAS NO DATA ON WHO HAS BEEN
VACCINATED FOR MONKEYPOX AND
DOES NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
COLLECT THAT DATA OR TO MANDATE
IT.
JANET HAMILTON, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE AND
TERRITORIAL EPIDEMIOLOGISTS SAYS
IT'S A NEW AND FAST-MOVING
OUTBREAK.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT ALL THIS
WITH HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SECRETARY XAVIER BECERRA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
ON A SCALE OF 1 TO 10, HOW
CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT THE
SPREAD OF MONKEYPOX IN THE U.S.,
ARE YOU MORE CONCERNED THAN A
YEAR AGO?
NOT A YEAR AGO, A MONTH AGO.
>> A DAY AGO.
ABSOLUTELY WE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED, 100% CONCERNED.
WE'VE NOT HAD MONKEYPOX THE WAY
WE HAVE SEEN IT NOW, AND WE
DON'T WANT IT TO BE A PART OF
LIFE THE WAY WE ARE SEEING IT.
SO WE HAVE TO STAY AHEAD OF IT,
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO SINCE DAY ONE.
WE HAVE INCREASED THE NUMBER OF
VACCINES THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE.
WE HAVE SOME 3,000 CASES
REPORTED.
WE SUSPECT THERE'S MUCH MORE
THAN THAT.
BUT WE HAVE ABOUT 300,000 PLUS
VACCINES THAT WE HAVE NOW MADE
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
>> TWO POINTS YOU JUST MADE.
FIRST OF ALL, ON A SCALE OF ONE
TO TEN, HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU
TODAY?
>> CONCERNED?
LOOK, ALWAYS CONCERNED WITH
SOMETHING THAT'S COMING THAT WE
HAVE NOT HAD TO DEAL WITH
BEFORE.
SO 10.
>> 10?
>> YEAH, BECAUSE WE WANT TO GET
AHEAD OF IT.
YOU DON'T WANT IT TO BECOME PART
OF LIFE.
BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE DIED
COMPARED TO COVID?
ZERO.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT'S A MAYOR CONCERN FOR THOSE
PEOPLE AFFECTED AND EXPOSED.
YOU SAID WE SUSPECT MORE CASES
THAN THE 3,000 REPORTED.
HOW MANY MULTIPLES ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
>> THAT'S WHAT IS TOUGH.
WE NEED THE STATES TO FEED US
DATA SO WE HAVE A SENSE OF
HOW -- WHAT KIND OF VOLUME, BUT
TO KNOW HOW TO CONCENTRATE THE
HELP THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
>> I WAS SHOCKED WHEN YOU
LEARNED THIS, THAT IT IS
VOLUNTEER FOR STATES TO SHARE
ANY DATA ON MONKEYPOX WITH THE
CDC.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE WITH ALL
DISEASES AND ALL VIRUSES.
THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
MANDATORY IN TERMS OF REPORTING.
SHOULD THIS BE MANDATORY?
>> MOST OF THE TIME WE CAN'T
REQUIRE THE STATES TO DO THIS.
ON COVID, UNTIL WE DECLARED A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY, WE
COULD NOT REQUIRE STATES TO
PROVIDE US DATA.
WE NEED THESE STATES TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE AND DEPTH
OF THE PROBLEM, BECAUSE WE HAVE
VACCINES AND TREATMENTS AND WE
WANT TO SEND THEM WHERE THEY ARE
MOST NEEDED.
>> THE W.H.O. DECLARED MONKEYPOX
A HEALTH EMERGENCY GLOBALLY.
THE U.S. HAS NOT DONE THAT.
SHOULD YOU DECLARE IT A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY IN THE UNITED
STATES?
WHY NOT DO THAT NOW?
>> WE'RE MONITORING AND KEPT IN
CLOSE TOUCH WITH W.H.O.
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN.
WE'RE IN A FAR BETTER PLACE THAN
MOST OF THE WORLD BECAUSE WE
PREPARED.
WE HAD VACCINES AVAILABLE BEFORE
MAY 18th, WHEN THE FIRST CASE OF
MONKEYPOX WAS REPORTED IN THE
U.S.
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE COOPERATION
FROM THE LOCALS TO GET THE
INFORMATION WE NEED.
BUT WE ARE PREPARED IN TERMS OF
THE TESTING, THE VACCINES AND
THE TREATMENT.
BUT EVEN THAT CAN BE OVERWHELMED
IF WE'RE NOT CAREFUL.
>> YOU KNOW RIGHT HERE IN NEW
YORK CITY, THE MAYOR HAS BEEN
PLEADING FOR MORE VACCINE FOR
WEEKS NOW.
I UNDERSTAND YOU SAY WE'RE
MONITORING, BUT YOU HAVE THE
POWER NOW TO DECLARE THIS A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IT WOULD GIVE YOU THE AUTHORITY
TO GET MORE DATA, AND YOU SAID
YOUR CONCERN LEVEL ABOUT
MONKEYPOX SPREAD IS A 10 OUT OF
10.
WHAT ARE YOU MONITORING FOR?
>> I SENSE THAT YOU'RE IN FAVOR
OF DECLARING A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY --
>> IF YOU'RE WORRIED, WHY NOT
MAKE THIS DECLARATION?
ARE THERE THINGS HOLDING YOU
BACK FROM DOING SNIT
>> BECAUSE WE DECLARE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES BASED ON THE
DATA AND SCIENCE, NOT ON OUR
WORRIES.
WE TRY TO PREPARE FOR THINGS.
SO OUR SCIENTISTS, AS WITH
COVID, ARE MAKING DECISIONS AS
WE SPEAK.
IF WE WERE IN A POSITION, AS
MOST COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD ARE,
TO NOT HAVE ANY VACCINES FOR
MONKEYPOX, TO NOT HAVING THE
TESTING AVAILABLE.
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY TO TEST
60,000 TO 80,000 PEOPLE ON A
WEEKLY BASIS.
WE HAVE ONLY HAD REPORTED SO FAR
3,000 CASES.
SO WE HAVE DONE WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO PREPARE, WE JUST NEED TO
COORDINATE BET WE ARE THE LOCALS
SO WE'RE FEEDING EACH OTHER THE
RIGHT INFORMATION.
YOU MENTIONED NEW YORK CITY.
THEY HAVE RECEIVED MORE VACCINES
THAN ANY OTHER CITY IN AMERICA.
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE DISTRIBUTING IT IN A WAY
THAT PREVENTS OTHER
JURISDICTIONS FROM SEEING WHAT
WE SEE RIGHT NOW IN NEW YORK
CITY.
>> YOU BRING UP OTHER
JURIS
JURISDICTIONS.
SO THE GOVERNOR OF ILLINOIS HAS
CALLED ON YOU TO TAKE MORE
AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO COUNTER
MONKEYPOX OUTBREAK.
SAN FRANCISCO'S CITY SUPERVISOR
IS QUOTED IN THE L.
A TIMES SAYING THIS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN A PREVENTABLE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS, HAD MONKEYPOX RECEIVED A
STRONGER RESPONSE IF IT WERE NOT
PRIMARILY AFFECTING QUEER FOLKS.
I WONDER WHAT YOU SAY TO THAT
CONCERN.
>> WELL, WHAT I CAN SIMPLY SAY
IS, THERE IS NO OTHER PLACE IN
THE WORLD WHERE THEY HAVE
300,000 DOSES OF VACCINES THAT
THEY HAVE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
STATES, AS WE HAVE HERE IN
AMERICA.
THERE IS NO OTHER PLACE IN THE
WORLD THAT HAS PREPARED THE TYPE
OF TREATMENTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR MONKEYPOX THE WAY THE U.S.
HAS.
WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT WE ALL
KNOW WHAT IT TAKES, THOSE WHO
ARE KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
MONKEYPOX, TO PREVENT THIS.
WE NEED EVERYONE TO HELP.
THIS IS NOT COVID IN THE SENSE
THAT IT IS NOT AS CONTAGIOUS.
BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
CONTRACT.
CLOSE CONTACT MEANS YOU'RE
PUTTING YOURSELF AT RISK OF
CONTRACTING MONKEYPOX.
SO WE NEED HELP FROM THOSE WHO
ARE IN THOSE VULNERABLE GROUPS
THAT MIGHT CATCH IT.
WE NEED HELP WITH THE LOCALS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
VACCINES.
WHAT WE CAN DO IS WORK WITH
THEM.
BUT WE NEED INFORMATION, DATA SO
WE'RE DOING THIS THE RIGHT WAY
TO PROTECT ALL AMERICANS.
>> SPECIFICALLY, WHAT HELP ARE
YOU ASKING FOR FOR THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE RIGHT NOW, MEN WHO
HAVE SEX WITH MEN, WHAT ARE YOU
CALLING ON THEM TO DO?
>> WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY,
AND WE THANK THE LBGTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY FOR THE HELP THEY HAVE
PROVIDED IN GETTING EDUCATION
AND INFORMATION OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY WHAT MONKEYPOX IS,
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE, WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO CONTRACT IT.
AND WHAT YOU SHOULD DO IF YOU
THINK YOU MAY HAVE IT.
SO ALL OF THAT INFORMATION
HELPS.
THEY WOULD THEN REPORT TO THEIR
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS.
WE NEED THOSE LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO COORDINATE
WITH US, SO WE HAVE THE DATA
THAT HELPS US DRIVE OUR SUPPORT
WHERE IT'S NEEDED MOST.
>> I WOULD BE REMISS NOT TO ASK
YOU ABOUT TOMORROW, MARKING THE
AMERICAN WITH DISABILITIES ACT.
THE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES PUT
OUT A STATEMENT SAYING LOOK,
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HONOR THESE
ANNIVERSARIES, BUT MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE, SPECIFICALLY THEY'RE
CALLING FOR MORE FOCUS ON
IDENTITY AND EMPOWERING PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES TO LEAD,
HOUSING, EMPLOYMENT, REMOVING
BARRIERS TO POLITICAL
PARTICIPATION.
WHEN I THINK OF NEW YORK CITY, I
THINK WE'VE GOT 126 OF OUR 472
SUBWAY STATIONS THAT ARE
ACCESSIBLE FOR FOLKS.
AS WE CELEBRATE THIS ANNIVERSARY
TOMORROW, WHAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE?
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING, I
REMEMBER AS A KID GROWING UP,
YOU COULD WALK TO THE DOOR OF
THAT RETAIL ESTABLISHMENT AND I
COULD WALK IN, BUT SOMEONE WHO
WAS DISABLED MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THE AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES
ACT IS SAY NO ONE WILL BE LEFT
OUT.
EVERYONE WILL BE INCLUDED.
WE HAVE HAD THREE DECADES OF ITS
WORKING.
BUT BY GOD, WE'RE GETTING TO THE
POINT WHERE EVERYONE IN AMERICA
WHETHER BE INCLUDED.
WE TALK ABOUT RACE, COLOR.
DISABILITY, AS WELL.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERY
AMERICAN WANTS AND THE A.D.A. IS
THERE TO HELP ENSURE THERE IS NO
DISCRIMINATION.
>> SECRETARY XAVIER BECERRA,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.